il en parle toujours avec la même
gourmandise nous avons peut prendre
entre dix et douze gammes d'escargots
escargots terre du berry dont qui se
compose entre guillemets de de verrines
qui ont pâti d'escargots qui se tartine
sur des petits toasts
ensuite vous avez à la tomate basilic
l'huile d'olive toujours la même recette
aux piments tiller et au citron vert et
cetera et cetera
avant d'en arriver à ces produits
goûteux il y à un lent processus
l'arrivée des naissains les bébés
escargots ils sont nourris avec un
mélange de céréales et de sels minéraux
jusqu'à leur maturité à 6000 élèves
rapportent entre 70 et 80 minutes cargo
à l'année une fois qu'ils sont arrivés
ici ils sont triés calibré et après sont
empaquetés dans des filets qui sont
comme ça pour justement passé en
laboratoire c'est quoi les laboratoires
c'est là où toute la magie s'opère où
tous les goûts et les gourmets selon
vienne vienne à moi justement pour
manger des mots produit la fin de
l'année est une période de très forte
activité pour l'escargotière c'est la
période la plus importante de l'année
donc il est préférable que les personnes
commande à l'avancé exactement mais moi
on est sur des clients de dernière
minute mais bon on a toujours de quoi
laisser reviens je t'en prendre deux ont
des voix là depuis jeu jusqu'à septembre
c'est une attention continue
et puis ces escargots sont élaborés avec
soin est ce qui fait que la la qualité
forcément au rendez vous en six ans des
gros gris élevé et cuisiner en berry en
leurs inconditionnels
moi j'aime bien les l'escargot qui en
croquis parce que justement il ya cette
pâte qui entourent l'escargot qu est
très agréable à manger après
j'aime bien les scarabées rit parce que
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
manger des escargots froid mais à
l'apéritif c'est excellent l'histoire a
commencé comme un jeu d'enfant six ans
après c'est une activité de niche
certes mais une activité avec son
enseigne